here in this country we're learning more
about the federal investigation of the
president's son Hunter Biden sources
tell CBS News the FBI and IRS believe
there's enough evidence to charge the
younger Biden with crimes although not
in connection with his business dealings
overseas senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington Catherine good morning
good morning Nate a lawyer for the
president's son slammed the allegations
as inaccurate and claimed Hunter Biden
is a target simply because of his family
name Hunter Biden's lawyer also called
on the justice department to investigate
how information apparently leaked from
within the FBI
multiple sources tell CBS News the FBI
is believed for months there is enough
evidence to prosecute the president's
son with tax crimes and making false
statements on a gun purchase the sources
said the FBI sent its findings earlier
this year to the U.S attorney in
Delaware David Weiss was appointed by
President Trump and is yet to bring
charges he's got to make that final call
under the principles of federal
prosecution not the initial call that
the FBI has made in gathering evidence a
lawyer for Hunter Biden called the
apparent leak inherently biased
one-sided and inaccurate adding their
team believes prosecutors should not be
pressured rushed or criticized for doing
their job the years-long federal
investigation into Hunter Biden's
business practices began before Joe
Biden was president Mr Biden has
consistently denied knowledge of his
son's work as he did here on the
presidential campaign Trail I've never
spoken to my son
the Federal Criminal probe explored
whether the younger Biden his uncle
James and other business associates
violated tax money laundering and
foreign lobbying laws earlier this year
the probe narrowed focusing on
delinquent tax payments including income
Hunter Biden earned as a board member
for a Ukrainian Energy company a source
close to the president's son said he
repaid more than a million dollars in
past due taxes in an interview last year
with CBS news's Anthony Mason Hunter
Biden downplayed potential charges
there's a federal tax investigation into
you where does that stand now they're
they're investigating I can't really
talk about them other other than to say
is that I'm fully cooperative and I'm
fully confident that at the end of the
day it's all going to be fine
the time in coming four weeks before the
midterm elections seems to raise the
political Stakes even though President
Biden is not on the ballot senior
Republicans say they will investigate
the Biden family businesses if they take
control of key committees in January
Tony
it's often said no one is above the law
Catherine thank you very much